[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous ça des preuves c'est bien evelyne
thomas et là vous vous dites mais qu'est
ce qu'elle fait en quatre pour touche
par touche pas où il fallait dire touche
pas à mon poste on a vous a pas briefé
baba à lâcher le manche pour me tendre
une carotte que j'ai saisira dans les
médias ça va être mon bébé et avec mais
non je suis de ma vie leurs médailles en
tout cas est de votre côté il ya de la
malchance
qu'est-ce qui peut alors voir aussi
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu peux avec les deux
bouffées le matos jean luc est ce que tu
aurais l'extrême amabilité remonter la
mécanique de l'expert médiane ici la
confiance espère bien j'avais eu avec
toi t'en fais pas leur bonhomme de
chemin quand tu alors un expert avant de
donner mon analyse j'aimerais lancer
tout de suite chez vous franchement tout
de suite tête de rongeurs les médias ça
fait mal sort on se rate un peu aussi
dit [ __ ] j'aimerais bien être
quatre visites et oisive asie ta
chronique chez moi je dors avec cyril
suivent encore ok madame ben ouais je
m'entoure tadjau
[Applaudissements]
ouah
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bakary kamé un mail lui s'est caché là
on va coucher liars
[Musique]